hey i'm dave rubin welcome to the rubin
report which is vladimir putin's
favorite show okay we've got two of my
favorite guests jen hoffman and dave
holmes i was just informed they did a
pilot together once called gasps psychos
yeah which uh well okay we and never
aired never aired never aired pilot we
will try to find it and bring it to you
next time alright we got a lot of great
stories for you and we're starting off
with this the stoli boycott in Russia
you know we talked about this last week
the Olympic 2014 games are in Sochi
Russia and Russia has been doing a slew
of anti-gay stuff all these new anti-gay
laws they can arrest gay people now
there's been a ton of hate crimes all
absolutely terrible stuff and in
response to this the gay community here
in the United States and all over the
world actually spearheaded by Dan Savage
who is a sex therapist but somehow has
become like the end-all be-all to the
gays are launching a boycott for Stoli
vodka products let's take a look at the
statement so this is dan Savage there is
something we can do right here right now
sabat wrote to show our solidarity with
Russian queers and their allies and to
help draw international attention to the
persecution of gay men lesbians
bisexuals trans people and straight
allies in Putin's increasingly fascist
fascistic is that a word fascistic
Russia dump Russian vodka we can also
show you the image of the the official
boycott logo because you gotta have a
logo if you're doing a boycott a shared
on Facebook there no one knows to do
unless you how to share yeah you have to
you have to share everything now real
quick it should be noted that actually
Stoli is not even based in Russia they
left Russia about 10 years ago they're
based in Luxembourg also they're
involved in a lawsuit with the Russian
government about branding right now they
have sponsored gay pride things in the
past they're sponsoring gay stuff right
now they've already issued plenty of
statements backing the gay community
this seems completely misguided to me
this is like boycotting Snapple because
you don't like America's drone use or
something like I just don't see the
connection between a company and the
government are you guys with me on this
it's can
fusing because I'm not exactly sure if
it's Luxembourg or Latvia but supposedly
the holding company that still owns it
is Russian base right and they still
make it in Russia right raw materials
are still Russian I think it's still
distilled in Russia so it's something
you know what does that does that make a
difference like digital does a vodka
company run the Russian government and
make their law these kinds of things I
think affect the wrong people I don't
think Vladimir Putin is really gonna be
too bothered by it I think I gonna you
know the people who provide the potatoes
or whatever goes in I'm not really
living wherever like in a field to need
their income from actually making the
vodka or now my maybe could be affected
by it but not the government yeah it
seems to me like a boycott is something
you do when it's like you don't like an
episode of modern family or whatever or
like you know to me like this is a
serious thing like they're throwing gay
people and trans people in jails it's
not like you know it's not like oh we
don't like you know they don't have
enough social services for lesbians in
Russia no they're like wholesale putting
gay people and their supporters in jail
this needs to get serious so like you
know yeah I think this thing is kind of
weak but if it makes people take notice
then it's a good thing I think let's put
all our cocktails away for five minutes
and figure out what it is that we're
actually gonna do let's let's pull out
of this Olympics right so you think the
United States should actually pull out
of the Olympics do you think that that's
like a legit because this is such a
severe human rights issue you either
believe that gay people are people or
you don't and if you believe that there
people then then this is wrong yeah you
can't you can't it doesn't you can't go
halfway yeah yeah it's kind of like the
chick-fil-a thing I mean people
boycotted chick-fil-a when they're
saying you know they obviously are
giving money towards anti-gay marriage
you know things but then in the end
chick-fil-a I still prevailed still
exists or stole a line around the corner
to get in so it's it's great that it you
know it'll make people more aware
there's media awareness we're talking
about it Russia eventually we'll have to
make some sort of statement if they feel
like at least rushing companies maybe
not putin himself right so the media
awareness is great it's great that
people feel like they're doing something
but just the absence of drinking a
certain vodka and ordering a different
vodka instead at a bar like you were
saying just you know put down the drinks
and maybe talk about it isn't really
going to affect any social policy and
any
change or anything real do you think you
also actually strengthen the other
side's hand in a weird way because
chick-fil-a is the perfect example their
sales had never been better when this
whole thing was going down with them so
you may end up yeah you're going to hurt
Stoli which was just the random what
there's plenty of vodka company is in
Russia they picked Stoli to attack but
you may end up helping other Russian
vodkas although some other vodka
companies from outside Russia are now
really doing a lot of promotion and
promoted tweets on Twitter because they
want to jump on the anti-russian I don't
think the thing bowl first of all the
thing was never just dan Savage started
as queer nation and he sort of gave it a
bigger platform or whatever and it also
has never been just dump Stoli that's a
that's a quick and easy way it was
alright but it seemed for whatever
reason it seems to have jumped on storm
is cheap and easy to bind people
recognize Stoli and because it actually
has you know assets from Russia and a
lot of things some of it says bottle it
they all say different things by the way
different bottles of it I was just in
Palm Springs this weekend and every
single restaurant there that I saw don't
do that I don't know if they have this
in West Hollywood right now haven't been
out in party in west hollywood in a
while but in Palm Springs which is
obviously a very gay friendly community
the restaurants do have signs up but
specifically say we are now not serving
Russian vodka you know they have a
little rainbow martini glass and it's
all very cute and Italy I didn't know
about it so at least it did raise my
awareness it raised the awareness of
people that i was there having my brunch
with we're very aware at brunch come on
having bright we're just pretty gay so
you already doing st. projets okay
there's a bunch of straight people
having some gala brunch yeah um brunches
they're gay or like annoying girls I'm a
dying girl so I was having brunch um but
yeah I mean Italy's love being set next
to you your people about our boyfriend
both in right honourable and are still
in our clothes from last night being
terrible terrible people the best brunch
is terrible thing yeah boy huh brunch we
got right about that yeah yeah I know
but I think in in the first place it did
make us talk about that it did raise a
little bit of awareness at the table I
think a lot of other people coming into
the restaurant we're wondering wine at
least thinking about it and then it made
you go okay what's really going on in
Russia and look a little deeper in that
so that was a good thing but in the end
and get it didn't affect anything
specifically it's not gonna change
Russia's policy known in Russia feel no
no the gay you know or bisexual people
in Russia or now like I
better thanks a lot no jail that my
family has less money because they're
not buying my potatoes or whatever but
yes I don't think out of jail because
you're not buying my potato right now
right yeah I do think that these things
do kind of help a little bit divestment
in South Africa you know I'm not gonna
play sun city all that stuff it raised
awareness and it worked eventually right
like you know little steven himself did
not end apartheid but it worked right so
did our thigh tired so do you think that
in the short term that perhaps harming
some of these companies which again
we're all agreeing you're just really
harm harming the potato guys and the
people that work in the factories that
really in the bigger picture that is it
worth it you know do the ends justify
the means in a case like this I think so
I do i do think so and if it makes Stoli
rethink their practices a little bit
because you know right now you know you
said that they're they're like you know
they they invest in the gay community
they advertised as a gay community right
a market to us but isn't that but that's
what all companies so a little bit
deeper right but that's as you're saying
chu tho now it's making all these other
Russian vodka companies come out and
through their Twitter and through the
all there were social media things
making really strong statement saying we
do support the gay community so even in
just that that you're making other
companies go out there and say hey but
we support you even if it's American
companies of any companies now are being
like okay we don't want to be associated
with being anti-gay or any sort of you
know hate-filled statements if it's
helping organizations feel like there's
going to be pressure on them you know to
be more supportive than it is worth it
yeah do you guys think there's any risk
in connecting companies with countries
so closely regardless of the country and
again not diminishing the importance of
this issue with the gay community Russia
just a company to industry people do
associate vodka with Russia maybe maybe
miss Association obviously like rigors
is in France and there's different you
know different alcohol comes from
different places than we assume but that
being said it is when you think Russia
you do stereotypically think vodka so I
think that way you are at least
attaching it to something that's a
little bit larger or more of an industry
than a specific company true and of
course look at the same point we get oil
from Russia we get oil from Saudi Arabia
where they still be head gay people but
you know you can't figure out exactly
where your oil is coming from when you
go to to the gas station so it's
obviously very complex and and we're
gonna we're gonna keep talking about it
yeah I needed we're going to finish this
with a nice bottle of Stoli okay